bonsoir et merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
de ce mercredi 18 novembre
comme chaque jour nous revenons sur
l'actualité locale entouré de nos
invités des journalistes de la rédaction
commence tout de suite avec les titres
de cette édition en raison de l'état
d'urgence les mesures de sécurité
renforcées en france les lieux qui
reçoivent du public doivent multiplier
les contrôles nous verrons comment
s'organisent les salles de spectacle et
chaque année depuis huit ans en novembre
les entreprises de l'économie sociale et
solidaire donne à voir ce qu'elles sont
et ce qu'elles font pour le grand public
sont proposés des rencontres des
découvertes des présentations en plateau
laurent diot d'un directeur de l'ig
rennes et cindy bkr directrice de
profession sport 78 et enfin à mort
passe est une institution la librairie
du centre pourrait malgré tout fermé en
raison de problèmes financiers nous y
reviendrons et en marge de la sau en
seine-saint-denis de ce matin le projet
de loi visant à rénover les dispositions
de l'état d'urgence a été présenté en
conseil des ministres une annonce déjà
faite lundi lors du congrès qui s'est
tenu à versailles le texte prévoit une
prolongation pour trois mois mais aussi
la possibilité pour le ministre de
l'intérieur d'assigner à résidence tout
personnes constituant une menace
autre point clé les associations ou
groupements portant une atteinte grave à
l'ordre public pourrait être dissous les
perquisitions administrative décidée
sans l'accord d'un juge serait facilitée
le texte sera examiné jeudi à
l'assemblée nationale et vendredi au
sénat avant de voir comment vont réagir
les élus à ces évolutions nous avons
voulu savoir ce que vous en pensiez
regarder les réponses avec ce micro
trottoir
oui parce que nécessité fait loi
oui monsieur parce que c'est une
question de sécurité c'est important bah
effectivement je pense qu'il faut
prolonger l'état d'urgence je me suis
retrouvé moi même avec mes enfants au
stade de france vendredi soir et j'avoue
que ce qui nous a rassurés c'est de voir
justement la mobilisation
de toutes les forces de la police ou
l'armée c'est évident ça c'est clair
cc c'est encore plus que vigipirate là
c'est donc un étage supérieur est
effectivement mais je pense que les
tailleurs chose c'est nécessaire à mon
avis il vaut privilégier la sécurité sur
la liberté donc l'état d'urgence mais
paraît nécessaire
ah oui tout à fait tout à fait parce
qu'en fait on est en sécurité et les
gens aillent sont un petit peu
malheureusement traumatisé par ce genre
de choses donc il faut continuer
effectivement et je te perds c'est qu'il
ya kong qui a accompagné lundi le
congrès du président françois hollande a
réouvert ses portes mardi matin
l'établissement public et son parc sont
restées fermées tout le week-end à la
suite des attentats de paris
la majorité des entrées sont restées
fermées pour mieux encadrer les
visiteurs la grille de la chapelle du
dragon des matelots de l'étoile royale
et saint-antoine au chesnay sont
désormais fermés des mesures de sécurité
supplémentaires pourraient être mises en
place dans les prochains jours
et enfin après les attentats de vendredi
dernier à paris sur notamment visé le
bataclan et le décret du plan d'état
d'urgence les salles de spectacle ont dû
s'organiser rapidement pour continuer à
accueillir les spectateurs des
dispositifs de sécurité particulier ont
été déployés dans les salles de concerts
de cinéma ou encore de théâtre
impliquant du personnel supplémentaire
et des contrôles renforcés
les détails avec william l
ce sont des habitudes qu'il va falloir
prendre depuis le décret d'état
d'urgence samedi dernier les salles de
spectacle ont dû renforcer les contrôles
à versailles au théâtre montansier on
procède à une fouille des sacs mais
aussi ouverture des vestes
un dispositif plutôt bien reçue par les
spectateurs c'est dans notre intérêt
dans l'intérêt de tous les tous les
français paraissait contractuels face
c'est très important je ne sais pas si
c'est important mais il faut faire pour
être sûr ça rassure les populations
danse est une bonne chose
des contrôles accrus qui ont un coût
puisqu'il nécessite des moyens humains
supplémentaires vérification des sacs
par des contrôleurs qu'on a pris en
complément deux des équipes d'accueil
habituelle et au lieu de contrôler
public à l'intérieur du bâtiment on les
contrôle à l'extérieur du bâtiment avant
qu'il ne rentre dans le hall
l'accueil est très positif les gens
comprennent et surtout ce qu'on souhaite
dire c'est qu'il faut remplir les salles
de spectacle c'est la meilleure réponse
aux événements du 13 novembre une
fréquentation des salles en baisse
depuis trois jours la plupart des salles
ayant été fermés durant le week end les
cinémas aussi procède à ces contrôles à
l'ugc de skywest des rondes sont
organisées en plus des contrôles nous
avons une masse de population qui peut
être important dans une centre dans dans
une salle de cinéma donc il faut qu'on
veille à tous que ce soit à ce que les
issues de secours fonctionne
correctement au cas où d'une évacuation
particulière que derrière nous nous
faisons le maximum pour veiller à la
tranquillité des gens et donc les
contrôles soient assurées en amont mais
aussi dans la salle une fréquentation en
baisse significative ici également
depuis ce week end du un état
d'inquiétude ambiant et cette image à
présent c'était mardi hier soir à
montigny le bretonneux les façades de
l'hôtel de ville étaient aux couleurs du
drapeau français
si pour des raisons de sécurité la
commune n'a pas souhaité organiser un
rassemblement populaire
elle témoigne de sa solidarité avec
cette initiative symbolique à travers la
france mais aussi à travers le monde de
nombreux bâtiments ont ainsi été
éclairés de l'opéra de sydney en
australie à la porte de brandebourg en
allemagne en passant bien évidemment par
la tour eiffel et nous recevons plateau
deux invités ce soir pour parler du mois
de l'économie sociale et solidaire
laurent guillot d'un bonsoir vous êtes
directeur de migraine votre association
d'éducation au développement durable a
pour objectif de faire naître et grandir
initiatives solidaires et responsables
toutes générations confondues et cindy
becker bonsoir vous êtes la directrice
de profession sport et vie associative
une association au service
des associations elle a pour objectif le
soutien au dirigeant associatif
alors vous êtes là ce soir pour nous
parler du mois de l'économie sociale et
solidaire qui se déroule donc au mois de
novembre
l'économie sociale et solidaire je le
rappelle sarah sont des entreprises qui
cherchent à concilier solidarité
performance économique et utilité
sociale elle représente 10 % du pib et
près de 12 la bulle 7 % des emplois
privés en france alors plusieurs actions
se sont déroulées dans les yvelines vous
avez voulu mettre l'accent sur un
élément particulier cette année
alors cette année ce que l'on a essayé
donc il rêve depuis cinq ans et
organisateur du mois de l'économie
sociale et solidaire pour le département
des yvelines
et chaque année on met ses draps tente
de rassembler pardon différents acteurs
afin de décider d'une thématique commune
cette année malgré de nombreux appels on
s'est retrouvé quelques uns autour de la
table mais le choix a été fait de
laisser libre cours à chaque structure
de mener ses propres initiatives
donc on peut noter que par exemple la
mutualité française en partenariat avec
la ville de la verrière qui participent
et co organisent le mois de l'économie
sociale et solidaire vont tenir des
événements
à propos de la parentalité le je regarde
mon papier le 20 novembre 2015 à 10
heures dans la maison de quartier du
bois de l'étang
moi j'invite toutes les personnes
souhaitant aborder cette thématique de
la parentalité d'aller participer de se
présenter au bois de l'étang alors il ya
le lundi 23 mai ni tables rondes qui
également organisé donc en partant avec
eux donc ils grain et profession sport
et vie associative 78 alors on va parler
de mise en place de la complémentaire à
de complémentaire santé obligatoire et
de la mise en place de la déclaration
sociale nominative
alors le lien avec le l'économie sociale
et solidaire c'est au niveau des
employés les associations c'est bien ça
effectivement notre objectif
aux deux structures c'est de parler de
thématiques qui vont les concernés
directement et d'avoir une à bord
vraiment pratico pratique donc c'est
vrai que 1 des soucis actuels c'est
l'emploi dans les associations
et effectivement les deux grandes
thématiques qui s'impose aux employeurs
qui ne sont que des bénévoles il faut le
rappeler ce ne sont pas des
professionnels de l'emploi
c'est évidemment la dé la dsn donc la
déclaration sociale nominative pour les
associations employeuses et
effectivement cette fameuse
complémentaire santé quand on entend
parler à l'échelon national
mais c'est vrai que les associations
sont un petit peu un petit peu les
parents pauvres parce qu'une fois de
plus ce ne sont pas des ce ne sont pas
des drh ce ne sont pas des patrons de
pme pmi ou d'entreprises beaucoup plus
importants qui sont de fait bien au
courant de ça qui maîtrisent les tenants
et les aboutissants donc nous de par
notre vocation départementale de soutien
au secteur de l'économie sociale et
solidaire dont font partie les
associations principalement on s'est dit
on va faire intervenir des experts sur
ces deux thématiques pour aider les
bénévoles à à s'en sortir à partir du
1er janvier 2016
là aujourd'hui on a donc le 10 novembre
il ya aussi des ateliers qui ont été
organisées à voilà où la mi novembre
si vous pouvez déjà tirer un premier
bilan exposé déjà satisfait de cette
édition
alors c'est aujourd'hui un peu compliqué
de tirer un bilan à ce stade là
2 du mois de l'économie sociale je
préfère rester prudent quant à annoncer
des chiffres
moi ce que j'invite encore à faire c'est
toutes les structures qui se mobilisent
dans le cadre de ce mois de l'urss à
aller s'inscrire et à inscrire lors des
événements pour donner plus de
visibilité sur le site le mois de l'ess
point orgue et nous reviendrons par la
suite pour faire le bilan et en tirer
les conclusions à docu alors en 2014
donc la loi économie sociale et
solidaire a été adoptée je le rappelle l
encourage un changement d'échelle de
l'économie sociale et solidaire fond
d'une stratégie de croissance plus
robuste elle donne également aux
salariés le pouvoir d'agir et de
soutenir le développement local durable
donc ça a créé un certain engouement au
niveau de l'économie sociale et
solidaire
aujourd'hui voilà on a en 2015 ça fait
presque un an un peu plus d'un an un an
et demi
qu'est-ce que qu'elle est un peu votre
bilan par rapport à ça vous sentez que
l'engouement est toujours là où
peut-être que ça s'essouffle à un petit
peu on doit paraître on remarque que il
y à pleins d'initiatives sur les
différents territoires vraiment le ss
qu'il faut bien rappeler un c'est que
c'est l'objectif de l'élite des
créations d entreprises c'est d'avoir
une économie locale non délocalisables
qui va s'adapter aux problématiques des
territoires et il ya pas mal de remonter
de création de structures telles qu'une
coopérative d'activités et d'emploi
aujourd'hui qui rassemble dix
coopérateurs la forge à la verrière qui
a vu le jour au printemps dernier il y à
un fab lab qui a vu le jour et également
sur la ville de la verrière et au sein
de versailles grand parc dans la commune
de versailles
donc on recense des initiatives des
porteurs de projets sont présents mais
en parallèle
il y à une baisse de financement
générale à laquelle les acteurs de la
société civile et bien sûr se plie comme
toutes les autres structures
collectivités communes et ça freine
ça va freiner les mises en oeuvre de
projets les idées sont là les envies
sont là les accompagnateurs de ses
projets que ce soit des accompagnateurs
financiers des accompagnateurs de la
formation des porteurs de dispositifs de
portage d'emploi ou des orienteurs tout
le monde est présent toute cette
dynamique et présente on voit la
préfecture qui souhaitent se mobiliser
aujourd'hui le conseil départemental
également commencent à se pencher sur la
thématique de l'économie sociale et
solidaire la direction jeunesse et
sports également donc là pour reprendre
une expression que j'ai entendu il n'y a
pas très longtemps il ya un bon
alignement des planètes pour développer
le ss dans le département des yvelines
mais plus particulièrement sur le
territoire de la casse qui essaient
maintenant qui va falloir mener le
chemin tambour battant
voici les vainqueurs vous sentez qu'il y
avait aussi des gens qui viennent nous
voir voilà pour travail en tant que
bénévole aux associations il ya un
engouement aussi de ce niveau là où
peut-être que c'est plus compliqué à
mettre en place
non on a effectivement à travers notre
centre de ressources et d'information
pour les bénévoles une recrudescence des
entretiens de personnes qui veulent
créer leur association soit en tant que
bénévole parce que ils ont une cause
effectivement à défendre au niveau local
mais également pour créer leur propre
emploi
c'est vrai qu'on saigne dynamique on a
observé depuis depuis quelques temps
voilà deux personnes des initiatives
vraiment individuel de personnes qui
veulent créer leur propre emploi à
travers une association donc après voilà
nous de leur expliquer que c'est pas si
facile il ya des possibilités mais
effectivement on se retrouve vite et là
je rejoins tout à fait les propos de
laurent on se retrouve vite dans une
un dédale de difficultés au niveau parce
qu'il ya des régions en france 9 heures
je pense aussi de la france où la
l'économie sociale et solidaire marche
très fort et justement où il ya beaucoup
d'engouement et beaucoup d'entreprises
qui se créent par rapport à ça au niveau
des yvelines
enfin un autre niveau
on observe cette effectivement cette
envie même au niveau des institutionnels
mais après les réponses financières
tarde à venir
c'est simplement un problème un problème
financier pour cent des voix c'est un
département quéré il ya alors ya la
problématique financière mais qui est
pas forcément liés au département je
crois qu'avec les dernières élections
municipales ensuite les collectivités
fallait des collectivités
d'agglomération qui se sont constitués
avec pour certaines des changement
d'exécutif avec des nouvelles
orientations politiques selon l'entente
est ce qu'on comprend avec les
régionales également qui arrive à grands
pas donc les sources de financement sont
encore existantes
mais aujourd'hui on doit faire preuve de
d'une recherche active et d'une
pertinence aiguë accrue pour pouvoir
obtenir ces financements et l'idée c'est
de bien structurer cette action est cet
accompagnement à destination des
porteurs de projets pour éviter de
rajouter des dispositifs et des
millefeuilles va des couches au
millefeuille et qu'on évite de se perdre
justement pour qu'on parle de l'économie
sociale et solidaire y avait aussi la l1
là comme 21 qui devait avoir le 30
novembre alors nous serons à bientôt si
elle est maintenue ou pas donc on va ils
ont forcément des attentats de vendredi
c'est un événement que vous attendez sur
lequel vous comptiez peut-être mais
l'association y bien entendu nous on se
positionne sur la thématique du
développement durable et de l'éducation
au développement durable au sens large
du terme qui pour nous est est un modèle
sociétal le développement durable j'ai
vu tout à l'heure un tweet de l'elysée
qui elle disait qu'ils risquaient
d'annuler toute autorisation de
manifestation dans l'espace public
pendant la coop 21
ça serait complètement regrettable
d'annuler ce genre de manifestation et
pour ça moi j'invite tous les gens à se
rendre sur internet il y a eu
aujourd'hui un appel pour le maintien
des mobilisations citoyennes pour le
climat qui a vu le jour donc je vous
invite à parcourir ce même ce document
et éventuellement elle signe enfin une
dernière question avant de terminer cet
entretien en 2014 vous avez fondé à
venir ce sont 18 donc le projet à venir
soit 118 vise à soutenir et
développement de l'économie sociale et
solidaire via l'appui aux acteurs de
l'économie sociale et solidaire donc les
civils qu'en est il aujourd'hui un petit
peu on est ce projet justement c'est une
belle illustration des difficultés
convient de vous évoquez si
effectivement on et voilà les quatre
structures départementales avec des jeux
et puis il inactive apporter
effectivement à venir 78 nous nous
sommes vus revus après je dirais l'année
de lancement où il y avait eu les
premiers financements ça s'essouffle
parce qu'effectivement on a du mal
à savoir ou demander les financements et
à une fois qu'on sait où les demandé à
entendre une oreille attentive rapport à
cette initiative départementale donc le
projet et pas du tout arrêter mais il
est en suspens pour c'est pour ces
raisons notamment financières c'est ça
2014 on a réussi à mener toute cette
agitation des différents acteurs qu'ils
soient institutionnels tête de réseau
accompagnateurs formation emploi et
acteurs de ss on a réussi à mettre en
oeuvre un plan d'action court moyen et
long terme
donc ça nous amène à fin 2014 et c'est
vrai que sur l'année 2015
l'arrêt du soutien financier fait que
les financements qu'il ya eu problème de
financement en revanche ça n'empêche
qu'en parallèle les acteurs de l'ess est
ce qu'ils soient associatifs mutuelles
fondations en coopérative aujourd'hui
les nouveaux entrepreneurs sociaux
souhaite toujours se rencontrer parce
que c'était un point fort de cette
concertation ce qui était ressortie au
niveau de la transversalité et c'est
aussi dans ce cadre là qu'avec yvelines
activons par excusez moi qu'avec
profession sport et vie associative 78
on a souhaité réaliser cette
manifestation du 23 novembre pour que
les gens se rencontrent autour d'une
thématique que la loi va obliger de
mettre alors je le rappelle donc la
table ronde de l'économie sociale et
solidaire a lieu le 23 novembre à 14 de
14 heures à 17 heures à la maison de
quartier d'orzy parc à la verrière merci
à vous d'être venu en plateau et d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
autre sujet maintenant créé dans les
années 1970 la librairie du centre de
maurepas envisage de fermer ses portes
dans les prochains mois les
propriétaires sont confrontés à des
problèmes financiers et perdre près de
10000 euros par an une pétition a été
lancée par les clients pour sauver
l'institution les précisions de michael
et demi d'euros éolienne elle l'a libéré
du centre de maurepas pourrait mettre la
clé sous la porte confrontait les
difficultés financières les gérants
envisage sérieusement de fermer la
structure ouverte depuis les années 70
la raison le nombre de clients a diminué
le commerce faire tous les ans dix mille
euros
le centre ville
entre élus mais moins de moins en moins
fréquenté les clients subissent entre
guillemets la crise moins en moins
d'achats et on subit aussi les
les achats sur internet est ce qu'il
faudrait c'est que les morlaisiens
changent leurs commandes hier leur
système d'achat essayer de penser plutôt
au petit commerce ils veulent que les
petits commerces restent mais on ne voit
pas forcément tous les clients ici pour
sauver la librairie une pétition a été
lancée par les clients plus de 1000
signatures ont été collectées ces
derniers jours il faut absolument les
soutenir nous on veut qu'il reste cela a
commencé à lire mon journal ou moi tous
les matins résolument qu'ils soient là
et qu'ils restent là on a besoin de six
apart
il y aura plus rien plus rien au
centre-ville ça c'est trop triste
ben je suis triste parce que moi
j'habite ici depuis très longtemps j'ai
été jeune
ici en faisant mes études et bien je
travaille à la librairie du centre plus
un endroit pour acheter un bouquin
un journal non mais c'est pas possible
c'est juste pas possible
un rendez vous est programmé entre les
gérants et le maire de la commune
grégory gary astier mardi prochain
l'hôtel de ville pour trouver une
solution
j'ai entendu dire où il ya une
possibilité mais ça il faut que mr n'est
que ce soit possible
un chouette les murs même face à un bail
emphytéotique qu'un loyer modéré pour
maintenir l'activité
une décision sur la fermeture définitive
de la librairie pourrait intervenir
début 2016 et on prend à présent à la
direction de plaisir le chantier de la
rd 30 se poursuit dans la commune dans
la partie nord le giratoire dénivelé
gatting prend forme après dix mois de
travaux les ouvriers travaillent
également sur un pont supportant la rue
régner un reportage de mie câline
d'euros et william l lancé en janvier
dernier à plaisir le chantier titanesque
de la rd30 avance sur la partie nord des
travaux le secteur du rond-point des
gâtines est actuellement en pleine
transformation
la centaine d'ouvriers mobilisés sur le
projet est en train de créer un pont
supportant la renier une voie de
circulation douce un giratoire dénivelé
le chantier est délicat sur un plan
technique c'est aussi un chantier
complexe avec des ouvrages d'art c'est à
dire des ponts des murs de soutènement
de la chaussée des gros terrassement et
une grosse complexité aussi en matière
de réseaux souterrains parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de canalisations d'eaux
pluviales d'eaux usées qui passe dans le
sous-sol certaines étaient prévus
d'autres l'étaient pas et donc il ya des
surprises au quotidien mais qu'on arrive
à traiter pendant la durée des travaux
la circulation est maintenue aux abords
du chantier trente mille véhicules
transitent chaque jour par le giratoire
des gâtines aux heures de pointe le
secteur est donc saturé en terme de
circulation
on n'a pas plus de nuisances que ce
qu'il y avait avant avant même que les
travaux ne commencent on était dans une
un secteur où les embouteillages sont
très forts donc on les a presque presque
un peu améliorée donc de ce côté là on
n'est pas assailli avec les gens qui ont
été trouvés même d'autres itinéraires
quant aux riverains on a un travail très
réguliers avec eux on a eu des beaucoup
de réunions d'information on a un site
sur lequel au jour le jour vous voyez
l'évolution du chantier
la livraison du secteur des gâtines est
prévue pour l'été 2016 la fin des
travaux de la rd 30 est elle prévue pour
coût total du projet 80 millions d'euros
et c'est une forme de pollution que l'on
voit un peu partout et dont on commence
à prendre conscience vous devez
certainement en avoir l'habitude les
déchets et les mégots de cigarettes sont
présents dans la rue sur les trottoirs
mais aussi dans les gares sur les voies
ferrées pour remédier à cette situation
la sncf expérimente actuellement une
nouvelle machine le glouton pour nous
ont parlé avec nous ce soir mélanie
gauthier france à l'anis le gueuleton
c'est cette machine un appareil 100%
électrique développée depuis 1995 par
une société belge
c'est en fait un gros aspirateur qui
permet d'aspirer du mégot de cigarette à
la bouteille de 2 litres
ça va dans un container de 240 litres
écouter ton adèle chose de directeur
commercial de france 2 glutton
l'avantagent de l'aspiration 7 au niveau
de frais de fonctionnement par rapport à
une grosse balayeuse qui l a déballé qui
frotte le sol 100 % du temps nous on va
se consacrer au décès qui sont sur le
sol
donc on a pas 100 % de la surface
quelques déchets donc on y vend au point
par point
alors les agents de nettoyage travaille
aujourd'hui sur les voies avec des
pinces donc on se doute que ça leur
permettre de ramasser les déchets les
plus fins mais les gars ont un trafic de
la journée comme ça se passe le
nettoyage est actuellement régulier mais
de nuit pour éviter le plus gros du
trafic et les agents ne peuvent ramasser
que les déchets les plus gros avec cette
machine de travail se ferait là aussi
tenue mais serait plus rapide et surtout
beaucoup plus efficace
l'appareil permet de régler la puissance
pour aspirer seulement les déchets non
pas les cailloux qui protège les rails
alors la sncf pourrait aussi faire un as
de nettoyage en profondeur des divers
ligne écoutez claire offredo elle est
responsable service et gares transilien
des lignes n ai eu pour nous c'est un
enjeu à la fois de perception on va dire
des voyageurs sur l'état de propreté de
la gare et du site et en particulier des
voix qui sont effectivement peu
accessibles dans la journée à cause du
trafic des trains donc on a des places
limité en temps pour pouvoir faire
intervenir les agents de nettoyage sur
ses sources et voir alors la machine est
présent dans une quarantaine de gares en
belgique en france est encore en phase
de test quand est-ce qu'on pourrait
avoir le glouton dans nos ghariani les
premiers appareils devraient être livrés
d'ici la fin de l'année dans plusieurs
gares de france et notamment celles des
communes de lyon et de marseille
du côté des lignes c n et u qui nous
concerne nous plus précisément à saint
quentin une à deux machines par ligne
pourrait être envisagée mais florane ça
n'empêche aux utilisateurs de préférer
les poubelles présente sur les quartiers
parce que c'est plus qu'une question de
propreté c'est une question de civilité
merci beaucoup mais un ami vous avez
bien raison et enfin en ce qui concerne
les mégots sachez qu'à paris depuis
jeudi 1er octobre
jeter un mégot de cigarette sur le
trottoir coûtera aux fumeurs la somme de
68 euros contre 35 auparavant et pas d'
excuses car la ville a installé près de
trente mille nouvelles corbeilles
cendriers pour les 350 tonnes de mégots
ramassés chaque année à paris et enfin
cinéma succès surprise au box office de
l'année dernière la comédie-française
baby sitting s'offrent un deuxième volet
les comédiens pour la plupart révélé au
grand public sur canal+
étaient présents à l'ugc de saint
quentin en yvelines pour une
avant-première le film sortira le 2
décembre dans les salles wilfrid richy
et patrick jacques de dixmude faire rire
malgré les événements l'équipe du film
baby sitting de a donc décidé de se
rendre à l'ugc lundi soir ou en avant
première devant une salle comble les
acteurs ont assuré le service après
vente de cette comédie qui aura la
lourde tâche de s'imposer début décembre
entre james bond
hunger games et star wars quand tu vas
au cinéma et que tu passe un bon moment
ça donne envie de retourner au cinéma
donc il ya en plus on n'est même pas sur
le même créneau c'est à dire nous on est
dans dans l'humour
il ya de la science-fiction bon c'est
vrai qu'il ya un peu de science fiction
parce que je suis dans le film mais ce
nom mais voilà on n'est pas du tout dans
le même créneau et le fait que les gens
et en masse au cinéma d'un illizi
retombe ce qui passe un bon baby cité
une premier du nom avait attiré plus de
deux millions de spectateurs dans les
salles
cette suite reprend ce qui avait fait le
succès de son aîné une bande d'amis
perdus dans la nature film est
principalement caméra à la main
seul le cadre change fini la région
parisienne place au brésil
oh potter mois
c'est la vraie difficulté d'un numéro
deux c'est de conserver ce qui a plu aux
gens tout en essayant de changer
suffisamment de choses pour que ce soit
pas exactement pareil donc c'est pour ça
qu'on est passé de la garde d'un enfant
à la garde d'une mamie dans le numéro 2
et voilà et c'est un film de fait dans
numéro 1 est une vraie comédie d
aventure dans dans le numéro 2 donc on
pense que grâce à tout ça avec le mode
de filmage du funk du fin de footage des
images retrouvées qu'on a conservé aussi
bon on pense que volage
on pense que les gens retrouveront ce
qu'ils ont aimé dans le rhin notamment
cette bande de copains et mais quand
même avec pas mal de nouveautés
si ce deuxième volet était déjà en
projet pendant l'écriture du premier le
troisième épisode en revanche ne sera
étudiée qu'en fonction de l'accueil du
public à partir du 2 desserts et c'est
la fin de cette édition merci de nous
avoir suivis à suivre kiosque avec
sephora namani pour ma part je vous
retrouve demain à 18 heures pour une
nouvelle édition du journal je vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée